i'm sean duffy and for laura ingraham
and this is the ingram angle from new
york city tonight
take everything that's what attorney
general merrick garland signed off on
when he personally approved the search
warrant to raid trump's mar-a-lago home
last week now the war was finally
unsealed today and it actually created a
lot more questions for us for for
example what did the agents need to take
everything under the sun why was that
everything they need to take everything
attachment view of the warrant lists
property to be seized denotes agents
that can take any government or
presidential record created between
january 20th 2017 and january 20th 21.
that covers his entire presidency
and if this raid was so urgent because
the left claims our national security
could have been at risk after all then
why did it take days for them to
actually execute the warrant the judge
signed off on the warrant on august 5th
but the raid didn't happen until august
8th
do fbi agents actually not work on
weekends
and what's more
is that trump
would have uh had these documents for
more than 560 days since he left the
white house 560 days if this is so
serious really what took them so long so
far
as the actual so far as the actual
documents we have a list now albeit it's
not a very good list of what was taken
here's what could have been a threat to
our national security the grant of
clemency for roger stone a leather-bound
box of documents and two binders of
photos
there were boxes the agents designated
as top secret documents that trump has
since said
were declassified but we still don't
know what the agents were really looking
for
the washington post reports the raid was
related to nuclear documents but even
politico doesn't buy that writing
we've seen enough trump scandals in the
last seven years to know that sometimes
potentially explosive allegations from
anonymous anonymous sources failed to
detonate uh you wouldn't say huh well i
could have told you that any american
could have told you that the warrant
reveals the doj is investigating trump
over three different laws concealment
removal or mutilation of records
destruction alteration or falsification
of records in federal investigations and
the espionage act
what
that's it
that's the whole question
what
this is absurd on every single level
there's one more question i have that
disgraced deputy director andrew mccabe
may have actually answered for us and
that is
what's the end goal here
i'll be going through all of this
material very closely to figure out
whether or not there is actually
evidence in here that supports any of
the charges and i should say wolf any
other charges so the investigation is
not limited to the three statutes
they've cited on the search warrant hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else